Phil
hey Reg how you doing man I'm doing
great yourself good so what's going on
tonight man you're struggling you're
saying Super Beta in recovery what's
what does that mean what's what's a
Super Beta in recovery I'll use the I'll
use the store so I'm one of the products
of uh a single mother household right
you didn't have a father mom went
through boyfriends had stepfathers one
had actually abused us a little bit and
stuff so when I say Super Beta and
Recovery I mean like my whole
let's say belief system and identity is
rooted in beta-ness right like as you
hear it over and over again
um a quick story is I went to a strip
club in my early 20s bought a lap dance
and told the stripper how she should
better her life you know like looking
back like just for reference right like
you look back on these things and you're
like holy [__]
um just went through a bad breakup and
stuff too about eight months ago so
dealing with all that but I mean I've
used it as fuel right like a absolutely
crushing the gym all that stuff but I
still am not seeing results so I'm kind
of like you were like I'm results I'm
like okay I'm doing what rich is saying
I joined the 10 Community like all those
things but I'm still not seeing you know
like I get the choosing signals but I'm
like I know it's probably something
mentality wise that I'm struggling with
with kind of what we discussed where my
Beta mind is like be nice be caring do
all these things so I guess my question
for you is like how do you hack that you
know what I mean like I listen to your
your podcast I do I'm doing the seven
spokes like to the best of my ability
but there's that area that is it's
frustrating as [__] right so I got moff
and jiren in the chat they obviously
recognize you so have you talked to them
yet
uh not necessarily directly know about
it no okay but so so the ask here is how
do you fix the like how do you kill the
beta like is that what we're asking yeah
I mean like the mindset side of it like
because I'm doing a lot of the at least
in my opinion what I've heard you say
over and over again but battle is real
right
33. so how recently did you come across
like my content my podcast my book all
that stuff
um
four months five months yeah so you got
like 32 years and a whole bunch of
months of programming
in a you know condition that you're
comfortable with right so
you so you have to find time and you
have to find
you have to find it within yourself like
a lot of people will go and they'll be
like I'll watch a video and all of a
sudden yeah I've red pilled or I you
know they read my book it's like yes
I've unplugged from The Matrix I am I am
now a free minute but most of them will
go back most of them struggle most of
them
um do revert back to the old beta
Tendencies because it's a lot more
comfortable because I mean like the
reality of it is that like
it boils down to this man somebody said
it to me a long time ago you can either
love women or you can understand them
but you really can't do both
you know and it's like I'm the guy that
that puts out these podcasts every week
like I've got 82 episodes the unplugged
Alpha I have a hundred episodes before
the train wreck the first half of the
episodes that it was before the train
wreck it did with the clinical
psychologist who's also pretty red pill
too I've got all these other videos of
entrepreneurs and cars Channel and even
me I still have to deal with [__] from
time to time right you know with my LTR
and it's like
your you're gonna struggle with it dude
you're just gonna struggle with it
because you grew up on a steady diet of
be a nice guy be a shoulder to cry on
buy her flowers you know caller text her
tell her she's pretty tell her she
smells nice put her up on a pedestal
you've been through a life of that and
it came from family it came from your
mom it came from Hollywood it came from
sitcom TVs it comes from marketing
campaigns that make men look like
bumbling idiots and women you know the
Fantastic hero of the queen of the world
sort of thing so
it just takes time it just takes time it
just takes getting getting comfortable
with a new version of yourself it takes
it takes putting yourself first it takes
asking yourself questions like you know
like who's whose frame am I in when I do
this right you know if you're with a
woman and like
I still do this like I was in um I was
in Mexico a couple weeks ago on vacation
a little fam Jam
um you know family the girlfriend stuff
and it's like
Mexico has some nasty [__] okay there's
some there's there's garbage on the road
there's some shady looking characters
and walking down the street you just
sort of comfortably walk down the street
and I found myself from time to time
with her on the outside and me on the
inside and that's not how it's supposed
to be you want to be on the outside as a
man because that's how it's always
traditionally been like the strong
masculine virtuous guy is there to
protect her because she's a woman I'd
rotate I'd spin her around she'd
recognize it I mean she knew what I was
doing but it's these little things dude
and it's not just oh I read a book or I
learned about Alpha [__] and beta bucks
or I uh you know women will break rules
for the alphas but they'll make them for
the betas and you know you hear all
these sound bites and they're all cool
and everything like that and it's and
it's just easy to sort of memorize them
sort of thing but it's applying it to
your life that's that's going to get you
to level up it's going to get you to the
next
level of achievement you know if you
know what I mean like what are you
struggling with you said you just had a
pretty bad breakup so what happened
there tell me about that I think the
best thing when you say what I'm
struggling with I mean obviously
mindset's a huge one of the beta
conditioning that's all I don't want to
go over the same thing we hear over and
over again but the one thing that hit me
the most was in your book when you talk
about the feelings of PTSD yeah that's
kind of like what I feel with women
right now is like when it comes to that
trying to be intimate or be funny or
talk to them or any of that stuff you
just almost get that PTSD so I'd say
in all other areas I'm doing fantastic
right like I've really been crushing the
gym I started investing like other like
I said the 10 group all the other areas
are going really good but with women
there's that like PTSD aspect of it
that's what do you mean like you have
um ongoing PTSD from the last
relationship like is that what you mean
yeah probably like well one night this
is I guess the big word too is like I
can't say I honestly
like yeah of course I miss her like all
those things of course right but I can't
honestly say that I'm like oh I need her
back right now not at all it's more so
it's still affecting my ability to move
forward and progress in let's say
spinning plates or anything like did she
do something did she like yeah
I mean I don't have confirmation but I
mean you can look back and kind of see
what happens so she monkey branched
essentially right so I was really good
in the beginning and then over time six
seven eight points in it starts slowly
going off and then she suddenly didn't
have time and then she ditched me a
couple of times and said she had a baby
shower and then you know later told me
she was out with friends at the club
right like and just like those types of
things and then she had a male friend
she had over to her house for coffee one
time you know so and I was like no like
I'm done I'm not dealing like I had
enough knowledge in that moment that
that was a boundary that I couldn't and
then she pulled back but essentially it
was monkey branching and then eventually
she broke up with me we had a fight I
have a son she is a son so single mother
um were you married before
no I was not okay
I had a bastard child my son's awesome
famous so [__] the kids were getting
along she tried to pull her kid away
from my kid we had a big fight then she
breaks up with me right so I'm like okay
whatever I was kind of relieved I was
like okay we got [__] to work on and
then like a couple months later she like
reached out to me and sent me a text
message that she's
in and she's over me she's in a new
Happy committed relationship now she
wants to make sure I'm you know right
like it was the cruelest thing anyone's
ever got so it really kind of threw me
off in a frenzy right where it was like
[__] because I cared about her and you
know all the things you say make sense
you think you have this relation uh ex
how do you say relationship Equity yeah
Equity yeah yeah right and then like it
just shits on you right it's my first
experience with it so it really [__]
with you right so that's kind of this
part where I'm like I don't want to get
into intimacy of any point because I'm
afraid of that all right so it's like
getting over that
how's everything else in life man is
work good you make good money
I work for an insurance company I make I
think I just got my T4 it's like 75k
last year like a
I make a living like it's not
where I want to be but I'm able to
provide right I take care of my son's
mom as well too with some child support
and stuff she's actually been really
good through that process which is nice
um
but yeah it's more so just that kind of
PTSD with women that's the only thing if
you would rate yourself on a score of
one to ten with 10 being the best
version of yourself and one the worst
where would you put yourself
I want to say six
yeah you're not gonna fight I mean
you've read my book right yep yeah
there's yeah there's a chapter in there
what I talk about dating and like you're
not going to find you're going to have a
great experience with women uh
responding strongly to you and being
reciprocal if you're only putting
yourself around a sex like I think in
the chapter on that I said don't really
bother with chicks unless you're at
least a seven or eight out of ten
um I mean you can improve your
the Optics of Attraction with uh great
photography but you can't Goose yourself
right I mean if you only believe that
you're a six or seven then you're only
going to see yourself as a six or a
seven so you have personal work to do
there yourself which which is gonna
which is gonna pay the biggest dividend
right like you hit the road running and
it's all for you it's not to get girls
it's not to attract more girls it's for
you it just it just so happens that
women will be a a byproduct of you going
from a six to an eight imagine how much
your life would change if you weren't a
six and you were an eight or a nine like
you're a good looking dude you look like
you're in good shape you obviously have
some things to fix right there's still
some limiting beliefs that you have in
your head see did you ever hear the bit
that I did with Sean on the uh safe
world theory
no I don't think so just give me a
second
so
we're like we build this house of cards
in our [__] head
about this
safe world you know that you create for
yourself oh if I invest in this gal
because she's got a son and I got a son
and I take care of them and we go out to
dinner and I protect them and uh you
know I dress up and I look good and all
that sort of stuff
um you know my car is clean I change
your oil I put under summer Tires in the
wintertime like if I do all these things
and you build this big [__] house of
cards around the whole notion which you
think is like a concrete building it's
like a safe world right and everything
within it is all it's all good firm and
strong the thing is though is that women
come in all the time and they kick this
thing down and it doesn't take much
right usually it's a sequence of some
things you know for you it was suspicion
um you know going out to clubs having
coffees with guys at our house stuff
like this
um but you didn't know how to set the
boundaries you didn't know how to
enforce those boundaries you didn't know
how to put yourself in a position where
you can walk away you didn't you
probably don't I mean you don't think
that highly of yourself if you're only
rating yourself a six out of ten right
so you can't you can't have a great
experience you can't enforce those
boundaries you can't
get really you know what you want if
you're not really the best version of
yourself so this always takes me back to
your best return on investment is on is
on yourself right maximize what you can
control minimize what you can't control
and double down on what your strengths
are because you know when you start to
double down on your weaknesses
um you know some people double down with
uh things that are strong weaknesses and
all they have is really strong
weaknesses right like I've had I've had
friends of mine that are like hey man
you know check out the link to this like
surgeon that can make you three inches
taller by breaking your [__] like uh
thigh bones and like stretching you out
over eight months and you know here's
some links to stuff and I'm like are you
kidding me like yeah like this is
something you can't really change okay
sure you can change it but all you're
going to have now is a really strong
weakness and you're going to [__] up
your body doing all this stuff for a
couple of inches right like so
you know it's it's doubling down on the
strengths and doubling down on the
opportunities that you have to improve
yourself what's in your head the
meatball between your ears and and
understanding what women really respond
to and how to get better results with
them and how to game them and how to set
boundaries and like deal with the vortex
of [__] that comes with long-term
relationships when you deal with women
over a long longer period of time
because
it's a different set of work dude right
like what is your goal you know is one
of the things that I'd be asked like
what do you want to do do you like do
you want to have a girlfriend do you
want to rack up your notches do you want
to have some experiences do you want to
get married again have more kids like
what is the goal for you right now
well I think that uh I heard Andrew Tate
saying I like it is I mean I had my 20s
where I partied and stuff and went
through the notches let's say but
um the way he said I like is the best is
like you have to become a player in
order to find the good girls and
eventually I do I mean for my son I want
to have I could be a good model for him
as well too that's probably my most
important thing and all of it like my
biggest motivator to not go back to Beta
and all this is I can't do that to him
right so
I will eventually do of course one I
have like a good solid relationship with
a woman to be a good model for my son
what do you mean do a course
what's that what do you mean by do a
course
did I say do a course I don't know maybe
I didn't hear you correctly no I don't
think I
like I don't think I said do of course
okay um sorry yeah I know eventually I
do want to have like a good solid loyal
loving woman right of course I think old
men inherently that's what we want we're
the romantics as you say right
um but I think you have to go through
the player phase to a degree to get to
that is so yeah you can't
yeah you can't identify gold unless
you've dug through a lot of dirt
because you go through dirt you go
through rocks you find some Fool's Gold
you might find some gold in there and
even when you find gold you still have
to polish it you still have to clean it
you still have to deal with you know
hundreds of thousands of years of [__]
that's all in the [__] crevices you
got to get out and all that sort of
stuff right so yeah there's some there's
some degree of yeah you need to be a
player if you want to find a good girl
because you can't distinguish good from
bad unless you've been around
right and you can't get good with women
unless you deal with women
right and I mean if you like really
attractive women
yeah I have a kind of thing if you're
like really attractive women you can't
be a six either right yeah or you can't
see yourself as a six
absolutely my ex was she was a model she
was one beautiful woman so I get it
right
um but I kind of have a theory a little
bit of a theory about how it works is I
think as as men when we're raised by
single mothers we're kind of wired like
women you know like when you talk about
a lot of the stuff I think that it's a
like when I talk about rewiring is we
have to rewire the way we think because
we've literally been raised by women so
a lot of the way that like don't be
aggressive don't so I started doing Muay
Thai about four or five months ago and
it just like unleashes the side of me
that I didn't even know was there you
know like so I think that it's like that
single single moms are beta factories
what they do is they build a better beta
even though they themselves are still
women and when they were younger and not
your mom they were they were like any
other girl out there they wanted to to
be with the strong virtuous alpha males
right those are the guys that they
wanted to be with but they probably
couldn't get the commitment from them
they end up having a kid dad doesn't
stick around they push that away any
combination of any of those things who
the [__] knows it doesn't matter you
never really get the truth unless you
talk to both sides anyway but her
strategy then is
um a lot of these single moms turn their
um turn their sons into
um what's the term I think they're
called Harrison Sons surrogate
surrogates or like or like husband Sons
where they basically try to build a
better beta out of their sun right where
they know what they're attracted to but
they also know what benefits them and
depending on how old they are and how
financially secure they are and if they
have a guy in their life taking care of
them they might actually try to
manipulate you and turn you into the
kind of guy that pays for their [__] and
takes care of them right and gives them
emotional support and gives them
financial support and all those sorts of
things too so it can be very very
problematic for young men when they end
up in a situation you know where they
become husband Sons where you know these
like girls will call them Mama's Boys
you know just to sort of be nice about
it but that's essentially you know like
the blanket term that women use to
describe them but it's not what the moms
call their sons but they're really just
building a better beta true yeah
absolutely true for me yeah so yeah
um so back to the original question
patience time you know
reads read some more books read some Evo
Psych
um keep a journal you know like if
you're single now and you're dating and
you're spinning place and you're going
to be a player keep a journal you know
went out with Becky she's this old this
is what she did for a living you know
this is the vibe I got most of them
never go anywhere right like you'll you
know you'll see them once twice maybe
after that nothing happens maybe it
escalates maybe it doesn't
um just make a concerted effort for
yourself to improve yourself and do
things that contribute to that
journaling is great for stuff like that
too I'm a I'm a I'm a strong supporter
of guys when they get their [__] like
[__] up like like you did go out and
spin some plates non-monogamous date you
know keep a journal you know keep some
notes fix
figure things out you know what I mean
like ask questions of yourself and don't
just sort of like go along for the ride
like we've always done in the past you
know where you just kind of like go with
the program that you've been getting it
why am I doing it this way why did she
behave that way uh you know like ask
these sorts of questions when you're
texting back and forth like if she's
doing the witty banter stuff or she's
maybe [__] testing you when you're
replying how quick you reply what you
reply with ask yourself you know
if replying with this is she going to be
in my frame or am I going to be in her
frame right like when you're dating like
one of the simplest things is she's like
oh yeah let's get together and let's get
that drink and she's like I live over
here at this intersection like in I use
Toronto for an example like I live in
Corktown so why don't you come down here
there's a cool little you know like
restaurant at the bottom of my condo and
that would be me entering her frame so
my response would be like no
um this is this is the area that works
for me we're going to meet at this place
at eight o'clock you know sort of thing
and the closer I can get her to
somewhere in the middle or closer to my
place she's more in my frame you know
sort of thing which means she's got more
desire for me so these are like some of
the games that you're going to have to
start to play to sort of get your head
around you know women that genuinely
like you and want to be with you rather
than the ones that are there more on a
transactional basis because you can help
you know with little Billy's homework or
zeroing in the scope in his BB gun
because his dad's an incompetent loser
or he's in jail or something like that
try to stay away from single moms by the
way yeah lesson learned yeah unless
unless they're a good fit like they have
a a kid that's the same age as your kid
and they get along or they could
potentially get along and she's a good
person and she doesn't need you sort of
thing like she doesn't need your money
she doesn't need you fixing [__] for her
all the time like
there's there's one exception I talk
about in my book in the chapter on
Single Moms I know you read it so you
get the idea yeah cool Phil
all right thanks Rich appreciate it
buddy I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out